I don't know how many of them was to
survive but I knew many of them died
before the coming of the soldier they
were so peaceful very peaceful singing
song because there are so many times
that they heard about the soldier were
coming and I decided
many of them have the preparation that
they would die and the reason why they
were so peaceful was at that time many
of them were writing their will the
letter to their parents they have the
preparation that they are coming back
the most shocking experience was the
first moment I encountered with the
killing and I by myself to say that that
person because at that moment I really
realized that the
I really know that soldier were
relentlessly shorter the citizens and
the students so that moment was very
shocking to me because when I walked
through the western part the streets I
was so startled that the whole street
was blood and at that time tank was
still occupying those across row there
were soldiers and all the fans were
broken torn down and one thing I didn't
understand understand at that time was
even the civilians apartment all the
windows were broken and then one of this
villain told me when the soldier coming
from the West
so crazy even the civilian the citizen
the student were running away they still
suit from the back there for the
citizens and their household it was so
angry and they saw everything they could
Akane's the soldier and therefore the
soldier simply fire back even after so
many years I
first you have to say I do miss them and
for the family I think it's such a
trauma that they cannot pay